what happens if you don't pay your taxes
hello my name is too cute I design
rocket-propelled clothes I came to earth
because I am fascinated by your shoes
there is no such thing on my planet I
have a great idea I will design
rocket-propelled shoes Europeans love
shoes I will make my shoes in the
European Union but if I set up a
business I'll have to pay taxes do you
know what happens if you don't pay your
taxes come with me let's investigate
[Music]
my rocket shoe factory will look like
this I am a financial auditor and I can
tell you that this factory is making
fake shoes you won't be making fakes
will you you won't be part of the shadow
economy what do you mean
the factory owner copies famous brands
of shoes and pretends their shoes are
the real thing they are not honest about
their activities they don't want to be
noticed that's the shadow economy the
shoes look great and they're cheap
what's the problem these are the fake
shoes that come from the factory it's
against the law to steal someone else's
ideas like this and people who sell
counterfeit goods don't pay taxes Oh
will someone try to steal my ideas for
rocket shoes if your shoes become famous
yes someone will make fake rocket shoes
to make money from your idea that's
counterfeit merchandise it's like
stealing how do you make money with
counterfeit merchandise counterfeit
merchandise looks like the real thing
but the price is a bit lower to attract
buyers who want famous brand shoes for
less money so they buy the counterfeit
shoes instead of my real rocket shoes
yes because the fakes use are cheaper
you would sell for your shoes so your
factory would lose money and maybe even
go out of business that's terrible
all my employees would lose their jobs
what happened why are the policemen
talking to him he has been selling those
fake shoes and he is trying to hide the
money the authorities want to know the
truth
why was he hiding money he didn't
declare the profit he earned from
selling the fake shoes so he didn't pay
any tax on it he was trying to keep it a
secret he was hiding in the shadows I
get it
he's not a decent citizen
[Music]
is everything alright you look confused
something doesn't add up
it looks like the business owner is
paying one of his employees under the
counter what does under the counter mean
it means the boss is not declaring this
employees earnings and isn't paying the
taxes he owes neither is the employee
that's not okay
it's called tax evasion evading tax is a
crime the boss and the employee are both
trying to evade tax does this affect
anyone else well the employee suffers
because he won't get health care or
unemployment benefits the whole
community suffers because the state
loses the income tax the employee should
pay what can you do about it I can talk
to the business owner or I can report
him to the authorities what will happen
to the business owner if he's guilty of
tax evasion he can be fined or even go
to prison what are you going to do I'm
going to talk to the boss and tell him
what I found out
then he must decide how to act
well done now the boss won't go to
prison and no one loses out why is the
man giving their salesmen that big bag
of money he wants to buy the car with
money he's hidden from the tax
authorities remember the shadow economy
yes but explain again why this matters
if you don't declare all the money you
earn to the authorities you are evading
tax this means the state budget gets
less money to spend on the well-being of
all citizens
[Music]
why did you tell your friends not to buy
ice cream from this van it looks
delicious
because this salad didn't give them a
receipt for the ice cream they bought
what is a receipt our receipt is a
written note that you get when you pay
for goods or services like an ice cream
you paid money and you get your ice
cream and receipt to say how much you've
paid but it was only an ice cream is a
receipt important is every business must
give customers or seat say how much
they've paid for things don't Worr aha
does this mean the ice cream woman is
hiding how much money she's making so
she doesn't have to pay so much tax yes
you've got a too cute that's why I chose
second ice cream fat because that ice
cream man gives receipts
he'd honest well done you're smart and
you're a good citizen now let's go to
the other van I want some honest ice
cream
[Music]
so much useful information about tax
evasion do you understand what the
shadow economy is have you ever read a
receipt for something you bought
[Music]
you